Oh, you know what?
Let's do this.
I'm going to put this furious Trampas Jimmy
from Philly.
We agreed he would call in because he has
some insane situation going on that I want
to hear about.
I hope we're able to talk about it rationally.
Jimmy, are you there, my friend?
Yeah, I'm here.
Okay.
So I want Jimmy.
Let me see if I can set this up, Jimmy, and
then I'll start getting your input on it.
Jimmy contacted me saying he had a go fund
me and ICE looked at it and it looks as though
Jimmy complained to me that someone stole
his Trump lawn signs.
But then in the go fund me, it looks like
Jimmy's raising money for legal fees because
he got arrested.
So, Jimmy, explain what happened.
OK.
So I'm sitting to do the day before someone
stole two of my prom signs.
OK.
I recorded that morning.
Someone stole another alarm, recorded that
one, too.
OK, now hold on.
Jenny.
Jenny, I wonder if we're gonna do this.
We've got to make sure we have the details
clear.
So I want to make sure we understand you.
You awoke and looked outside.
Your Trump signs were gone.
And you called the police and said, I'm reporting
the theft of my Trump sign.
Is that what you mean by.
I reported it.
Yes.
OK, good.
Got it.
Yes, they came out the first time and then
when I called the next morning, is that I
will just add it to the report.
Got it.
Yes.
Thanks also.
But anyway, so I say out there and I have
a few drinks and I'm basically guarding my
signs, you know, and for black young black
men.
And I never felt menaced, David.
They were having a ball.
They were gleeful.
They ran on to the wall.
And so quickly I didn't even have time to
stand up.
They grabbed for signs.
They ran into their car and they drove around
the block three times f whitey f trump.
Then they stopped at the light.
And I ran after them.
To stop the car.
Get my stuff out of my mind, you know, so,
um.
So, Peyton, that person didn't take a video
like that, but they took a video of me running
down the street like a lunatic.
OK, so, Jamie, let's pause.
Let's pause, because I don't want to miss
a second of this idiocy and I want my audience
to fully understand it.
This is now separate from the initial the
incidents you reported.
You're out on your lawn having a beer and
four men who you believe to be black and find
their race relevant.
They steal your lawn signs and drive away,
but then they're circling the block.
Is that correct?
Yes, they're circling the block screaming
f whitey, f trump.
OK?
And then even then we go out a little black.
I got eyes.
Pretty good vision.
I do wear glasses, but.
And then Jimmy.
And then.
So you run after the car.
You run out into the street and right after
the car.
Yes.
OK.
And obviously your car is faster.
Obviously, a car is faster than a person.
So does the car.
They will if they were stopped at a white
less than half a block away.
OK.
I want to go through the crowd.
They gave you out of the car.
Now they couldn't beat me up.
OK, but they had never had the intention.
They were just 20 some some 20 somethings
out.
Just trying to mess with mess would get you
know, they never like land.
And then they chased me back to my house.
Right.
Did the cops come to a stop?
Said to me, Listen, Jimmy.
He says, I understand about the Trump signs.
You're allowed to be drunk on your property
at the moment.
You step off your property.
Republicans drunk and I have to arrest you.
Okay, now, Jimi, hold on.
I want to commend you now that you're speaking
more quietly with your audio is coming through
so much more nicely.
So let's keep the quiet voice.
Now, here's the one detail you skipped over.
You claim that these four men chased you back
to your house and then the police show up
at what were these four guys doing then?
Did they run away while they they had left?
I mean, I guess the cops came maybe five minutes
later.
OK.
And the cop says you can be drunk on your
property, but once you leave your property,
it's public intoxication.
Yes.
And he said and because I have a video is
that if I didn't have the video, I would lock
you up because I.
But I have a video.
It's you.
And you got to go.
So I put my hands on my back.
I give no static.
So you are you were arrested for public and
toxic.
If I understand correctly, Drummy, hold on.
Correct.
You were a restaurant for public intoxication,
for chasing a car full of men who had stolen
your Trump sign in your neighborhood, right?
Correct.
OK, great.
So it gets better.
So they bring me to police station and the
intake cop says, well, I blow the breathalyzer.
They said, you're not that big.
Usually we get a call with a public drinking.
We're expecting holy hell, but we're not going
to cut you to the chair.
Don't act up, which I get.
He hands me my cell phone and he says, call
friend.
She's like, Dom, you can go.
I called three people, Alexandra, and he says,
look, you can sit there for an hour, call.
Just be.
Yeah.
I called my old boss recently, said, Jimmy,
I'll be there in twelve minutes.
One hour goes by.
Two hours goes by.
Three hours goes by.
I scream under the cell door.
Protocol is to test me.
You can hold me here all night just because
you want to set a common test.
I mean, they say you're just blowing on the
legal limit.
We're going to give you a ride home.
Gee, thanks.
So I called my lawyer and he said, Jimmy,
they got.
Basically, it's an unfortunate situation.
You know, he said I could probably bring into
the mitigation that signs were stolen before
and you know, that they were riding around
the block.
Tony, you you weren't taking correctly you.
But by law.
Yeah, you are.
He.
And he said, Jimmy, I'm going to play you
for hundred debride to lose.
Then you're gonna probably have to pay the
fine.
Right.
And the sarge decides for me.
Shut up, Jimmy.
Defiance two, three.
They would go for me in.
Initially I was trying to raise fifteen hunger.
OK, Jimmy.
But I.
We're just.
All I need to kind of manage this a little
bit because we're just all over the place.
So as it stands right now, it sounds like
you're saying you're not going to hire a lawyer
for 15 hundred because public intoxication.
It's not like you're gonna go to prison or
jail.
You're going to owe a few hundred bucks.
Is that right?
Right.
It's a fine.
Probably to 300.
Let's face it, David.
Fifty nine for a lawyer.
Who's telling me I'll try lose in.
This lawyer has never lost a case for me.
I mean, he's a bad boy.
I mean, I protested the lawyers bank for banks.
I've been arrested for protesting many times.
A beating case every time they write.
Yeah, I'd acted for 15 and probably two or
three more.
Four or five.
And lose a day's work.
Right.
So the smartest thing to do is take it on
the chin and pay the fine.
Do you think the smarter thing to do would
be not to drunkenly chase after people in
your neighborhood?
Is that smarter?
Well, the smart thing to do would be not to
go on my lawn and steal my property, right.
But I'm talking about you can only control
your actions, right?
You can't control those of others.
This is true.
But hear me out, David.
No, but here.
Hold on.
I want to keep get keep on the core part.
So in our conversations, you've revealed that
you were previously arrested for domestic
violence, which is why you don't see your
daughter regularly and now you've been arrested
for public.
Is that true?
I don't see my daughter regularly because
her mother has poisoned her against me.
I've seen my daughter for years after that
incident, took her to every amusement park
under the sun, brought to you by the hundred
dollar wristband it signifies.
And you go on the ride twice and all at five
hundred dollars.
I would spend every time I took the kid out
every Sunday.
All right.
Anyway, so I went to.
I mean, you know that you and I don't agree
on politics.
I reject your racist, xenophobic, homophobic
views.
But it sounds like you're in a tough spot.
So I'm sorry to hear that, David.
David, I'm far from a racist.
Let me explain to you how bad this country
has gone.
It's a very short story.
No, no, Jimmy.
Jimmy, I think you've.
I told you I would go to you if you called
in.
We've given you about twice the time most
callers get.
So let's put a pause on it there.
I think the audience gets the story now.
And I think we've done enough for one day.
Jimmy.
OK.
Yeah, but I just want to tell you that the
hard store is killing you, David.
I don't know what that is.
Is that a relative of yours?
Telling you PAC man fever, DNA, they gave
it back then power anymore.
You go and you go and you decide your brother.
I did a day earlier a lot of money.
And so many some of your leftist compatriots
come on to my channel and they are respectful.
And I get there's just I have to cut it because
there's just no ending it.
OK.
We're gonna go to a quick break and then right
back to the phone lines.
So don't hang up if you are holding The David
Pakman Show, David Pakman dot com.